a race in which the nation is waiting
for between Democrat U.S senator
Catherine Cortez masto and her
Republican Challenger Adam BlackSalt now
ballots need to be counted the race
could still go either way 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy has been at
election headquarters in North Las Vegas
pretty much a week and with the latest
update she joins us now Vanessa
more than 50 thousand ballots needing to
be processed as of noon Registrar of
Voters Joe Gloria says he believes most
of them can be processed by the end of
tomorrow that's Saturday again the end
of tomorrow but considering the pace at
which the county has been moving over
the past two days the question is how
here's why yesterday more than 12
thousand were processed the day before
about fourteen thousand again Joe Gloria
saying he's confident more than 50 000
can be processed in two days this is
video of ballots being processed today
some observers we've talked with say
they believe this is all running
smoothly others saying they feel Limited
in what they can see
some observers have said they can't
follow a ballot being processed from
start to finish is that true and if it
is true should that change in the
interest of transparency I think I've
mentioned on many occasions in Clark
County we're being more transparent far
more transparent than the law requires
us I don't make the law I administrate
so if they have any suggestions for what
they think should be allowed for them to
view or participate in those are issues
that they need to take to the
legislature and have them sponsor a bill
that would change the law
and as far as the criticism Nevada and
specifically Clark County is getting
regarding the pace here Gloria has been
saying the county is following deadlines
outlined in the law here now Gloria also
says nearly 10 000 signatures needing to
be cured that means they need signature
verification election workers are
working on that as well as groups like
The Culinary Union trying to reach those
voters so they can verify those
signatures that deadline is the end of
business day Monday we have information
at 8newsnow.com so voters can check on
their mail ballots and also see if they
are on that list of signatures needing
to be verified back to you all right and
Vanessa you've been giving us indicators
and next points but when do we see the
end coming
well I don't know about the end but I
will
significant uh a number of election
results if Joe Gloria says if Joe Gloria
keeps his promise that these majority of
mail ballots could be counted by the end
of Saturday then we would see
significant numbers tomorrow evening but
again as far as the end Commissioners
certify the results next Thursday back
to you Kirsten